welcome to the fourth and final
installment of Christmas with me eart um
at least for this year
2023 you know there are only four
Christmas sermons but perhaps we could
continue this little tradition in some
fashion next year um spending Christmas
with eard in some way there are a lot of
other sermons after all um if you guys
would be interested in that because I
have for sure enjoyed doing this little
thing every week it's been a beautiful
way of of just getting into to to the
Christmas mood in a different way by
thinking a little more deeply about some
of the uh implications and and
Theological
mystical aspects of this holiday which
is of course as we have said for eart
the birth of the Sun the birth of the
word not only in time as a human being
but in the ground of the soul and the
ground of God in the Eternal now in the
Eternal present Beyond Time where our
true home lies and into which we must um
break through detach ourselves from all
things and become unknowing so that we
can receive that birth um which as you
know as we've seen has been the main
theme running through all these sermons
that we have read um he has tackled this
theme in different ways from different
perspectives sometimes more
philosophically sometimes more perhaps
theologically or
mystically but that has been the main
theme of of Christmas that eart has
explored again I will say this that um
this will not be an introduction to eart
or his thought or his thoughts on
Christmas necessarily if you want that
then go watch the the first episode in
the series or my full video on eart and
his philosophy which I again I will
leave a card to up here and some links
probably in the description too
so for the final time we're going to
light the fourth
candle on what is now today Christmas
Eve this was a very
strange match I'm going to use another
one because I don't want to accidentally
burn the house down or something here we
go let's see if I can do this this time
as
well
NOP
there okay
sure I don't know when you're watching
this but here for me it is currently
Christmas Eve and in Sweden Christmas
Eve is when most people sort of
celebrate Christmas properly this is
like the main day for us here in Sweden
which is a bit different from from other
places perhaps for for most people
around the world um the main celebration
would be tomorrow on December 25th which
I guess is when this video will be going
up um but in Sweden we have this
tradition of of celebrating on the 24th
on Christmas Eve families will gather um
eat food together watch Mickey Mouse and
Donald it's a weird tradition we watch
Donald Duck at 3:00 every Christmas Eve
like literally every Swedish family does
the same thing um and it's one of those
strange and funny things that we just do
because we've always done it
um and it's interesting because as many
of you know Sweden is often seen as one
of the most secularized countries in the
world and yet Christmas is incredibly
popular right everyone loves and
celebrates
Christmas and and there is Food For
Thought there what what's going on there
and we can perhaps see in that a lot of
of what religion and
and rituals are about which I've talked
about in many of my videos which is this
this very profound social function that
these things have it's about coming
together as a society as a
family um it's
about like look here we have these
candles and then lighting candles and
lights you know fireplaces you know all
these kinds of uh there's a lot of this
imagery of light around Christmas you
know the Christmas tree and so on and so
in many ways I think Christmas is also
about bringing light into a very dark
period of the year and especially in
Sweden and Scandinavia it gets really
dark you know around this time of year
as I've said
so for people who even though they might
not be devout Christians or practicing
Christians Christmas becomes a very
important time of year because it is a
time that is associated with many of
these things of light and love and
family and coming together as a family
um for some people it's the only time
that they get to see their extended
family for instance um and so it becomes
a very profound and very important day
for a lot of people regardless if you
have a connection to the um religious
mythology
behind um the holiday as such but for
for eart which is what we're talking
about today um that mythology or that
story about Christ and and or Jesus is
of course Very Central uh but as always
for him it's not primarily about the the
physical historical person but rather
about the metaphysical and
mystical meanings of of what's going on
here the birth of the Sun
so today we're going to read the fourth
sermon again using the complete mystical
works of m eart translated by Maurice
oconor
Walsh and sermon
it's hard to say but sermon 4 might be
my favorite I think sermon 4 is just
incredibly beautiful there are some um
par paragraphs in here uh that I think
are just stunning and and you'll see
hopefully probably you will see what I
mean um there is some imagery in in this
sermon and ways that he expresses these
things that I think is just
wonderful um so without further ado
let's start this final
sermon the Bible verse that is discussed
that opens this thing is Luke
242 eard
says we read in the gospel that when our
Lord was 12 years old he went with
Joseph and Mary to the temple in
Jerusalem and when they left Jesus
stayed behind in the temple without
their knowing when they reached home and
missed him they sought him among
acquaintances among their kindred in
amidst the throng and they could not
find him they had lost him in the crowd
and so they had to go back to where they
had come from and when they got back to
their starting point the temple they
found him so this is the famous story
from the Gospel of Luke where Jesus Mary
and Joseph lose Jesus in Jerusalem at
the temple and they come back and they
find Jesus and he's preaching to the
rabbis there and you know he knows more
about the Jewish law than the rabbis
themselves a very story about the
childhood of Jesus and eart has a very
profound reading of this section which
he clarifies in the next paragraph here
and so in truth if you would find this
Noble birth you must leave the crowd and
return to the source and ground whence
you came all the powers of the soul and
all their works these are the crowd
memory understanding and will they all
diversify you and therefore you must
leave them all sense perceptions
imagination or whatever it may be that
in which you find or seek to find
yourself after that you may find this
birth but not otherwise believe me he
was never yet found among friends nor
among Kindred or acquaintances there
rather one loses him altogether
accordingly the question arises whether
a man can find this birth in any things
which though Divine are yet brought in
from without through the senses
such as any ideas about God as being
good wise compassionate or anything the
intellect can conceive in itself that is
in fact Divine whether a man can find
this birth in all these in fact he
cannot for although all this is good and
divine it is all brought in from without
through the senses but all must well up
from within out of God if this birth is
to shine forth truly and clearly and all
your activity must seize and all your
powers must serve his ends not your own
if this work is to be done God Alone
must do it and you must just suffer it
to be where you truly go out from your
will and your knowledge god with his
knowledge surely and willingly goes in
and shines there
clearly where God will thus show himself
there your knowledge cannot subsist and
is of no avail do not imagine that your
reason can grow to the knowledge of God
if God is to shine divinely in you your
natural light cannot help toward this
end instead it must become pure nothing
and go out of itself alt together and
then God can shine in with his light and
he will bring back in with him all that
you forsook and a thousand times more
together with a new form to contain it
all of this we have a parable in the
gospel when our Lord had spoken in in
such friendly fashion to the Gentile
woman at the well she left her picture
and ran to the town announcing to the
people that the true Messiah had come
the people not believing her words went
out with her and saw for themselves then
they said to her now we believe not
because of your words we believe rather
because we have seen him ourselves so in
truth no creaturely skill nor your own
wisdom nor all your knowledge can enable
you to know God divinely for you to know
God in God's way your knowing must
become a Pure unknowing and a forgetting
of yourself and all
creatures that was long section of
course but he uses this this story in
the Bible Joseph and Mary loses their
son literally right in the temple in
Jerusalem among the crowd of people and
they seek Him amongst their friends and
their kin they cannot find him anywhere
right so they have to go back to where
they started to the temple
and of course what this signifies to
eart is this going back to where we came
from right back to our ground the ground
of the Soul so forsaking we forget this
the birth of the sun that's taking place
within us all the time we sort of lose
that in in the crowd in in the in the
sense perceptions and all these things
that we experience in our lives whether
it be you know good or bad or anything
right any multiplicity all these things
that we experience in our lives we lose
that sun in all of that so we have to go
away from all that even our friends and
our kin and go back to the temple and
the Temple of course represents the
ground the soul The Chew our true home
and and there and of course we've been
through a lot of these themes that you
discusses there we become unknowing and
God can sort of pour His grace into us
because we are completely passive and
receptive and then there is the other
Bible quote that he uses here which is
that uh where he meets The Samaritan
woman at the well
right and and the the sort of of message
of that scene is that when she goes and
tells the people in her town they don't
believe her before they go and see Jesus
for themselves and so again that's a
sort of message to say her words
representing our own kind of knowledge
and our intellect what we can imagine or
think that can never make us truly know
we have to experience for ourselves
right so a clear again one of the the
the primary sort of features of
mysticism and people don't want to call
eart a Mystic right and there are
reasons you know people have reasons for
this they want to say he's a theologian
or a philosopher not necessarily a
Mystic perhaps a mystical philosopher if
anything but here I think is one of
those uh science that that that card
very much has a kind of mystical
epistemology right the only way to truly
know is to unknow the only way to truly
know is to experience yourself you know
rather than using your intellect or your
sense perceptions or your knowledge your
worldly knowledge because that can never
truly lead you to God so Echo continues
here now you might say well sir what use
is my intellect then if it is supposed
to be empty and
functionless is that the best thing for
me to do to raise my mind to an
unknowing knowledge that can't really
exist for if I knew anything at all it
would not be ignorance and I should not
be empty and bare am I supposed to be in
total
darkness certainly you cannot do better
better than to place yourself in
darkness and in
unknowing oh sir must everything go then
and is there no turning back no indeed
by rights there is no
returning but what is this Darkness what
do you call it what is its
name the only name it has is potential
receptivity which certainly does not
lack being nor is it deficient but it is
the potential of receptivity in which
you will be perfected that that is why
there is no turning back from it but if
you do turn back that is not on account
of any truth but because of something
else the senses the world or the devil
and if you give way to the impulse to
turn back you are bound to lapse into
sin and you may backslide so far as to
fall
eternally therefore there is no turning
back but only a pressing forward so as
to attain and achieve this possibility
it never rests until it is filled with
all being just as matter never rests
till it's filled with every possible
form so to intellect never rests until
it is filled to its
capacity so he says The Only Name that
there's darkness that we are to achieve
has is potential
receptivity right and you know I don't
think I need to explain this again right
this this complete passivity where all
our individuality and sort of active
aspects of our soul our mind is
completely shut off right we're
completely
know we might you know to compare we
might be able to sort of compare this to
certain aspects of indic thought not
just indic thought a lot of different
philosophical schools where we talk
about sort of pure subjectivity I guess
you could say that like the pure eye the
pure the pure self that is just the the
the experiencer the the Eye being aware
without there being anything necessarily
that it is aware of you know just
pure awareness receptive awareness right
if you can reach that then maybe well
eart say then necessarily God will
shower his his his being upon us or or
we will experience that in a direct way
unmediated way something that was always
there of course which is again this
birth of the son that he's constantly
talking
about on this point a pagan Master says
Nature has nothing swifter than the heav
heavens for they surpass all else in
swiftness yet surely the mind of man
outstrips them by its speed if only it
were to retain its potentiality intact
remaining undefiled and unrented by base
and gross things it would outstrip the
highest Heaven never ceasing till it
reached the summit there to be fed and
cherished by the greatest good as for
what it profits you to pursue this
possibility to keep yourself empty and
be just following and tracking this
Darkness an unknowing without turning
back it contains the chance to gain him
who is all things and the more Barren
you are of self and unwitting of all
things the nearer you are to him of this
barrenness it is said in Jeremiah I will
lead my beloved Into the Wilderness and
will speak to her in her heart the true
word of Eternity is spoken only in
solitude where a man is a desert and
alien to himself and a multiplicity for
this desert itself self estrangement the
prophet longed saying who will give me
the wings of a dove that I may fly away
and be at rest where does one find peace
and rest there truly where there is
rejection desolation and estrangement
from All Creatures therefore David says
I would rather be rejected and spurned
in the house of my God than dwell with
great honor and wealth in the tavern of
Sinners pretty profound uh uh paragraph
here I think uh talking about
the desert again this imagery that he
uses in in some of the other sermons too
um saying that God is him who is all
things right pretty uh profound uh
language there the more Barren you are
of self and of unwitting of all things
the near you are to him so so many of
these recurring themes in all these
sermons right you are just to rid
yourself of all your sense of self all
multiplicity all outside things that is
how you get to this this uh
place he continues
now you might say oh sir is it really
always necessary to be Barren and
estrange from everything outward and
inward the powers and their work must
that all go it is a Grievious matter for
God to leave a man without support as
the prophet says woe is me that my Exile
is prolonged if God prolongs my Exile
here without either enlightening or
encouraging me to work within me as your
teaching
implies if a man is in such a state of
pure nothingness it's not better to do
something to beguile the gloom and
desolation such as praying or listening
to sermons or doing something else that
is virtuous so as to help
himself a similar question to one of the
questions that were asked in the last
sermon right um but with a slightly
different flavor I would say so eart
replies here no be sure of this absolute
Stillness for as long as possible is
best for all of you you cannot Exchange
change this state for any other without
harm that is certain you would like to
partly prepare yourself and partly let
God prepare you but this cannot be you
cannot think or desire to prepare
yourself more quickly than God can move
in to prepare
you but even if it were shared so that
you did the preparing and God did the
working or the infusion which is
impossible then you should know that God
must act and pour himself into you the
moment he finds you ready do not imagine
that God is like a human Carpenter who
works or not as he likes who can do or
leave undone as he wishes it is
different with God as and when God finds
you ready he has to act to overflow into
you just as when the air is clear and
pure the son has to burst forth and
cannot refrain it would surely be a
grave defect in God if he performed no
great works in you and do not pour great
goodness into you whenever he found you
thus empty and bare this is a really
interesting quote I think because it
seems to imply and this might
be one of those sort of controversial
aspects of Art's thought is that it
seems
to say that God's
um what's the use what's the language he
uses there God must act pour himself
into you God must do that he must
necessarily do that so and even though
he he does that by his will because God
has a will that he acts by of course he
seems to say that this is not like a
being wants something and then does it
right he has to do this and this was a
common idea in certain
philosophical um schools right or
philosophical um currents at this time
right this debate over whether the
creation of the World by God was
necessary uh and there are a lot of
philosophers in in like for example the
Islamic world that held that idea such
as IB Cena or abisa very famously right
God just like the sun has to emit light
God has to create it's just part of his
nature so it's not something that he
sort of like a human being would like
choose to do like now I'm going to
create the world but it's just something
that his being just does that
automatically and that was controversial
because many people felt like well
you're taking sort of U agency away from
God um but another Islamic philosopher
that had a similar idea was of course or
aois and aois was incredibly
influential and and widely read and
studied in medieval Europe by people
like Thomas aquinus and of course by
people like M eart eart would have been
deeply um aware of of IB rush and his
Works especially his commentaries on
Aristotle which was sort of his major
work and so even though and not not
saying that this is like exclusive to
the Islamic thinkers but we can see that
this is kind of theme at least this is
what I think when I read this right it's
this idea of God's necessity God not
necessarily creates the world or in this
case God must necessarily pour himself
into you when you become receptive to
him it's just something that happens
naturally or automatically almost aart
says in the same sense the Master's
right that in the very instant the
material substance of a child is ready
in the mother's womb God at once pours
into the body its living Spirit which is
the soul the body's form it is one
instant the being ready and the pouring
in when Nature reaches her highest point
God gives Grace the very instant the
spirit is ready God enters without
hesitation or delay in the Book of
Secrets it says that our Lord declared
to mankind I stand at the door knocking
and waiting whoever lets me in with him
I will
Su and here I think is one of the most
profound and beautiful
sections of this whole sermon and really
of all these sermons in my opinion eart
says you need not seek him here or there
he is no further than the door of your
heart there he stands patiently awaiting
whoever is ready to open up and let him
in no need to call to him from afar he
can hardly wait for you to open up he
Longs for you a thousand times more than
you long for him the opening and the
entering or a single
act that's just incredible stuff
right imagery God is waiting just
standing right there at your door the
whole time right waiting for you to open
the door also reminds us of like certain
Sufi sayings and Sufi poems right um
this this incredible closeness of God
and this I love this last sentence the
opening and the entering are the the
same act or the opening and the entering
are a single act just such such great
imagery it reminds me of of um that
other most famous of Art's quotes right
the eye with which you see God is the
same eye with which God sees
you and here the entering or the opening
when you open the door to let God in
that is the same act as him entering
into
you right so it's sort of collapsing
that distinction between the one opening
and the one going in it's really at that
point in the ground it's all
one I was going to say is one thing but
it's not thing it's all one let's just
say right and this is just a beautiful
expression of
that he continues now you might say how
can that be I can't feel him pay
attention your being aware of him is not
in your power but in his when it suits
him he shows himself and he can hide
when he wishes this is what Christ meant
when he said to Nicodemus the spirit
breathes where it will you hear its
voice but do not know where it comes
from or where it's going in So speaking
he contradicted himself you hear yet
know not by hearing we come to know
Christ meant that by hearing it is emed
or absorbed as if to say you receive it
but
unawares you should know God cannot
leave anything void or unfilled God and
nature cannot endure that anything
should be empty or void and so even if
you think you can't feel him and or
wholly empty of him that is not the case
for if there were anything empty under
Heaven whatever it may be great or small
the heavens would either draw it up to
themselves or else bending down would
have to fill it with themselves God the
Lord of nature does not allow that
anything be empty or void therefore
stand still and do not waver from your
emptiness for at this time you can turn
away never to turn back again right so
so here he talks about that theme again
that that we talked about earlier God
must pour himself into the empty void um
there is this saying right nature hates
uh nature hates a void
right and a common opinion in Old
philosophy I think in aristotelianism
I'm not an expert on aristotelianism as
you probably um um sort of deduced from
these um sermons or my commentaries on
them but
isn't it Aristotle that basically says
that that there is no void right that a
void is impossible there's always
something whether it be air or whatever
it is there's no void at all which we
know today of course isn't really true
because atoms are mostly
void but you know we can go deeper into
that too perhaps it's like a Quantum
field which would not be aoid anyway um
a card says that God cannot allow a void
so when there's emptiness in this case
like the soul God has to
enter he says now you might say well sir
since you're always assuming that
someday this birth will occur in me that
the son will be born in me now can I
have any sign by which to recognize that
this has taken
place right so gets to the the me of me
of the discussion here right how how do
I know if this Birth has taken place we
know from before of course that the
birth is always taking place because
it's taking place in the Eternal present
but how can you know that you have sort
of reached this birth how can you come
to know this birth that's how I read
that's how I interpret what he's asking
here yes indeed there are three certain
signs I will tell you just one of
them I'm often asked if a man can reach
the point where he's no longer hindered
by time multiplicity or matter assuredly
once this bird bir has really occurred
no creatures can hinder you instead they
will all direct you to God and this
birth take lightning as an
analogy whatever it strikes whether tree
Beast or man it turns at once toward
itself a man with his back toward it is
instantly turned round to face it if a
tree had a thousand leaves they would
all turn right side up toward the stroke
so it is with all in whom this birth
occurs
they are promptly turned towards this
birth with all they possess be it never
so Earthly in fact what used to be a
hindrance now helps you
most your face is so fully turned
towards this birth that no matter what
you see or hear you can get nothing but
this birth from All
Things All Things become simply God to
you for in all things you know it is
only God just as a man who stares long
at the Sun sees the son in whatever he
afterwards looks
at if this is lacking this looking for
and seeking God in all and sunry then
you lack this
birth
right so when this birth happens it's
very obvious is what I think he's saying
right it's like the lightning strike you
cannot um you you can't miss it right
it's it's obvious everything turns
towards this it becomes this all cons
all consumed thing and then after you've
experienced
this everything becomes this birth
everything becomes God right again we go
back to this thing
right um You annihilate yourself in God
but then you return to multiplicity and
now you see everything as God wherever
you turn there is the face of
God all things become simply God to you
for you know is only
God so when you've experienced it birth
when you come to to that point where you
you you you've this Birth has occurred
in you so to
speak then you start to see God
everywhere everything becomes the Divine
there is nothing but God you're
completely consumed by this vision of
God as being all things all of reality
that's how I read what he's saying
here he continues now you might ask
ought anyone so placed to practice
Penance does he lose anything by
dropping penitential
exercises pay
attention penitential exercises among
other things were instituted for a
particular purpose whether it be fasting
watching praying kneeling being
disciplined wearing hair shirts lying
hard or whatever it may be the reason
for all this is because the body and
flesh are always opposed to Spirit the
body is often too strong for the spirit
and there's a real fight between them an
unseizing
struggle
so I think it's pretty OB obvious but
he's saying that all these outer
practices just like we discussed in the
last sermon all these are to sort
of balance this um Body
Spirit dichotomy within us right to to
to tame the body not let the body be
that which rules our spirit rather the
other way around
so he continues he says here in the
world the body is bold and strong for it
is at home the world helps it the Earth
is its Fatherland it is helped by all
its kin food drink soft living all is
opposed to
Spirit the spirit is an alien here but
in heaven are its kin its whole race
there it has good friends if it strives
for there and makes its home there and
so in order to sucker the spirit in this
alien realm and to impede the flesh
somewhat in The Strife lest it should
conquer the spirit we put on it the
Bridle of penitential practices thus
curbing it so that the spirit can resist
it right so just clarified what I just
said
before all this is done to bring it
under control but if you would capture
and curb it in a thousand times better
fashion then put on it the bridal of
love with love you overcome it most
surely with love you load it most
heavily therefore God lies in weight for
us with nothing so much as With Love For
Love resembles the fisherman's hook the
fisherman cannot get the fish till it is
caught on the hook once it takes the
hook he is sure of the fish Twist and
Turn as it may this way or that he is
assured of his catch and so I say of
love he who is caught by it has the
strongest of bonds and yet a pleasant
burden he who has taken up this sweet
burden fares further and makes more
progress than by all the harsh practices
any man use and two he can cheerfully
bear and endure all that befalls him
whatever God inflicts on him and can
also cheerfully forgive whatever evil is
done to him nothing brings you closer to
God or makes God so much your own as the
sweet Bond of love a man who has found
this way need seek no other he who hangs
on this Hook is caught so fast that foot
and hand mouth eyes and heart and all
that is man's belongs only to God here
love makes its
triumphant um entrance here right love
which is this
incredibly recurring theme in all of a
lot of mysticism Sufism is one of them
Christian mysticism is another one love
here becomes the
ultimate path to God right love
represents that that
direct path to to the divine right
however much we may pray or do all these
penitential practices if we can find
that true love which is at the core of
our relationship to God which is at the
core of reality in many ways if we can
sort of be in tuned with that love and
and be that love then that is the best
way to reach God and very very profound
and strong imagery here he Compares love
to the fisherman's hook right very
almost like violent um imagery here the
hook that that catches the
fish once you are caught by the hook of
love there's no there's no going back
right once you're caught by that hook
you can as he says it however much you
may twist and turn and try to go get
away it's you know you're done for
you've been you know you're caught by
the hook of love just like the moth in
in atarus Conference of the birds he
flies into the flame of the candle and
just burns just disappears dissipates
into the
flame and this is of course love of God
not necessarily love of
spouse or love you know worldly love but
um and I may be reading or sort of
projecting things onto eard here but I
think I think I'm doing so not without
reason is that love is one in a certain
sense right that yes it is love of God
but love of God is also love of your
children right or love of your family
love of your fellow man it's the same
love it's the same love manifest and
expressed in different
ways um the last sermon talked
about um the importance of outward
actions you know it can be annihilated
in God as much as you want but if that
doesn't make you love your neighbor and
give to charity and and take care of the
those who are in need and give to the
poor and so on then what's the use right
and that's love that's all love right
it's love of your fellow man is to love
your neighbor as
yourself it's the same love that is the
same love with which we love God and we
love God by doing those things that's
how I understand this right we love God
by loving our fellow man we love God by
giving to the poor we love God by
unconditionally
loving the people in our
lives and and giving to them and
forgiving them right he talks about
forgiveness here and and forgiveness is
of course very important to Jesus too
and all of Christianity we forgive each
other because we
love and that is the path that is the
true path to God when we can really
plunge into that love and really live
that love which is the True Foundation
of reality in some way it's it's
actually identical to the ground which
we will maybe see a hint of very soon
here so that's why I also think this
this sermon is so profound is that it
brings up love in such a profound way as
the sort of the key in many ways to
experiencing this birth at least that's
a sort of best way to do so and there's
so much we can talk about surrounding
love which we have just done but there's
even though I've talked about it now for
a couple of minutes there's so much more
we can say about it um but to me it's
it's of course not just about loving
God and God loving us but about this
this larger context where God where love
is one and love is not only felt for God
but but experienced and lived by by
extending it to those around us and to
the world in many ways
too he who hangs on this hook just to
read the last sentence again he who
hangs on this hook the hook of Love is
caught so fast that foot and hand mouth
eyes and heart and all that is man's
belongs only to
God we saw earlier that of course when
you when you realize this
birth everything becomes God you see God
everywhere so of course if you love if
you love God with all your heart and
then you realize that all of this is God
when you look into the eyes of an orphan
in a certain sense you're looking into
the eyes of God right
because there is only God but of course
you need to be aware of in what way
you're not looking at God at the same
time because you're also looking at the
world of Multiplicity which is
nothingness but if you know in what way
you're also looking at God then of
course you will love that person or that
whatever it may be you love them
unconditionally because it's all God at
the end of the
day eard continues he says therefore
therefore you cannot better Prevail over
this Foe and prevent him from harming
you than by love this foe I would assume
is is the body and its sort of fleshly
desires and all these negative things
that we or attachments that we have to
the world for example therefore it is
written love is as strong as death and
as hard as hell death separates soul
from body but love separates all things
from the soul it will not tolerate what
is not God or Gods whoever is caught in
this net whoever walks in this way
whatever he does is all one whether he
does anything or nothing is of no
account and yet the least action or
practice of such a man is more
profitable and fruitful to himself and
all men and more pleasing to God than
all the works of others who though free
from moral sin are inferior to him in
love very strong words here really
emphasizing that
this love is the strongest and most
powerful thing of all whatever he does
is all one a person who
is absorbed in this
love his rest is more useful than
another's
labor therefore just watch for this hook
so as to be blessedly caught for the
more you are caught the more you are
free just incredible quote there right
this Paradox that he uses I think is
also so powerful the more you are caught
by this hook of love the more you are
actually
free that we may be thus caught and
freed and may He help us who is love
itself
amen I think hopefully you can see why I
think this particular sermon is so
incredibly beautiful there are so many
paragraphs and quotes and sentences in
the sermon that I think are just so
so striking so profoundly
beautiful
um especially some of those sections
talking about that closeness of God
right right waiting right outside the
door just waiting for us to open and
then collapsing that distinction between
us and God by saying that the opening
and the entering is the same
act and then also and then also this way
he talks about love as the sort of
ultimate expression of of of um of
divinity relationship to Divinity
um and at the end he says that he he
identifies god with love God is love
itself um which is not
something like we haven't heard before
that we know God is love is like a very
common thing but with all that in mind
that we've talked about um including the
extent to which love sort of also
extends to our actions and not just this
particular relationship between the
human and God but also how that um
um how they informs our entire being and
our
entire um sort of existence and and
being in the world to ourselves and to
other things around us it just becomes a
very
profound and and
beautiful sermon in many ways and
especially you know when we've gone
through all these sermons and and this
theme of the birth of the sun which
represents this innermost experience of
of the presence of God the the Oneness
of of the ground of the soul and the
ground of
God and all these sermons have sort
of circulated around that theme in
different ways like the planet circling
around the sun right taken it from
different perspectives looked at asked
different
questions um and when we have all that
in mind and then we get to this part and
he ends it with this incredibly strong
message about love that love is the
ultimate just the ultimate thing but
then also which of course strengthens
that even more by saying that God
literally is love God is love itself and
I think what better way to end uh these
series of
sermons um and what a beautiful
message on
Christmas because to many people of
course around the world Christmas is
very much about love about
loving family about loving those around
you about giving giving is a is a Kind
of Love um one of the things people
associate most most with Christmas is
that we give presents to each other
right and not just within our family but
also a lot of people will really
emphasize you know giving away to
charity giving to the poor so Christmas
is very much much a a a
holiday about love and which love is a
very is a very central theme and so for
that reason it becomes especially
fitting the way that eart ends this
fourth sermon by so profoundly diving
into that ocean of love and explaining
it in such a beautiful way and in such a
Divine way
so I think again that's just an
incredibly fitting way to end this uh
this fourth sermon incredibly fit way to
end this series which we have been
calling Christmas with my
eart
um again I've really enjoyed reading
these with you and I've really enjoyed
seeing the response of course as you've
noticed they're not the most well
performing videos in terms of views but
the response to those real ones out
there whove been watching has been
amazing uh and it's been really
wonderful to share this uh with you
um I hope this has been some kind of
light in the dark December season and
that it's made your your holiday season
or Christmas season um a little bit more
meaningful in some way it certainly has
for
me um and you know at at this point
there I guess there's not much more to
say
than I hope everyone out there is is
doing well that your month is Meaningful
that you have a good holiday season and
I would like to wish all of you out
there a merry Christmas Happy
Holidays happy Winter Souls whatever it
is that you are celebrating or not
celebrating I hope um you experience
some of that light in your life which
many people associate with Christmas and
that love can play a role in your life
in a way that it also does for so many
people on
Christmas so I hope that that love which
to eard is always present everywhere at
all times um is is apparent to you that
it plays a role in your life in some
way again Merry Christmas happy holidays
I look forward to seeing you in future
videos so I'll see you next
time
[Music]